yes I've spoken to the leader of the
United States but also France and
Germany over the weekend we're
completely coordinated on our response
to this it's a situation that we've been
monitoring for some time the instability
that would be caused by Russia's illegal
invasion of Ukraine and what we saw over
this weekend as an example of that uh
coming to the fore it's obviously too
early to to predict with certainty what
might happen as a result of this but I'm
in close touch with our allies and we're
monitoring the situation closely I know
you prepared for a collapse of the
regime and there's documents today said
the UK needs to be prepared I mean this
is the most tooled up nuclear power in
in the world is the UK prepared for
Putin's collapse if it comes as I said
it's a situation that we've been
analyzing and monitoring for some time
because we're aware of the potentially
destabilizing impact of Russia's illegal
war on Ukraine and indeed the tensions
between the Wagner group and the Putin
regime that's why we're in close touch
with our allies to make sure that we're
coordinated it's too early to predict
with certainty what the consequences of
this might be but of course we are
prepared as we always would be